good morning morning it's 10:20 6 a.m.
the morning of day 8 now you'll notice
that we're posting two videos today I
personally had some issues with the last
Greece isn't so happy I burned that on a
skillet a fajita skillet apple I'm not
gonna edit you into the vlog my friend
Andy great guy love him but Andy is what
we refer to as a focused attention hog
there is dog hair all over my
comfortable Jonathan yeah motivated
independence attention want her this is
delicious
he likes the spotlight quite a bit he's
a little bit of a diva why I don't like
it when she do coke binges because
really nice too it's not like Mean Girls
per second it's another word for
absolutely to be the center of attention
reference you're never gonna get those
in this block remember how you weren't
supposed to be in this vlog attention
want her any way that he can but I'd
also like to note that Michelle and I
are sporting these purple wristbands and
I'm a nun normally we support these
purple wristbands and would you like to
explain what they are it's a theory that
if you go 21 days without complaining
it'll become a habit and make your
quality of life better so but no we're
not complaining I'm not complaining we
are merely pointing this out for the
benefit of you and our own sanity
yeah let's raise my three minutes I
think that's why I have so much problems
with my sexual identity so we're not we
love Andy he is our friend
I wouldn't have stayed up with him until
3:00 in the morning discussing breakups
if he was not my friend exactly
I would not have gone to bed at 1:00 in
the morning to let them have that
conversation if he was not my friend